did you know that you do not need a
large youtube channel to start
generating money the way you do it is
called affiliate marketing but i want to
encourage you in this training you're
going to learn some things that you've
never heard before and some new
information about really how you can
start generating money without having to
create your own product without having
to get monetized on youtube and i'm
excited because today i have my friend
pat flynn doing a deep dive master class
for free where you're going to learn
some powerful strategies in this very
session he's going to be talking about
how to find the right product this is a
huge key and he's going to be sharing
tips on that he's going to be then
sharing some specific video strategies
that will generate affiliate sales and
this is really cool because i haven't
seen anybody else teach this and then
stick around until the end because he's
also going to be teaching some of the
legal things that you need to know you
want to stay in compliance with this you
don't want to get in trouble with this
and unfortunately that's the missing
piece of a lot of the other videos out
there on youtube so buckle your seatbelt
this is a deep dive master class and i
want to encourage you to
really take some notes and get ready
because you're going to learn a ton of
really valuable information in this uh
video and training so get ready and i
want to welcome today
my friend pat flynn for this training
pat how's it going uh it's going awesome
sean i know affiliate marketing uh has
changed your life um and i'm excited
because we're gonna hopefully change
some lives today during this workshop
100 yeah for those that are maybe just
hearing my story you know think media
itself was started from me talking about
cameras camera tutorials
and
making videos and then being able to
eventually get financial freedom leave
my nine to five make money from home for
my family through youtube ad revenue and
affiliate marketing but it wasn't
youtube ad revenue that was paying the
bills it was affiliate marketing
single-handedly at first before all the
other stuff that we're doing at think
media today that was able to have us
reach that financial freedom and i know
you
are like my favorite affiliate teacher
you have a whole program on it and by
the way full disclosure for everybody i
actually asked pat
to share more information about how you
can go to the next step at the end of
this training in his 123 affiliate
marketing uh course but either way watch
this entire video whether that's right
for you or not and we'll tell you more
about that later but without further ado
i want to dive into this core content so
are you ready to go pat yeah i got a lot
to share a lot of the stuff i haven't
really shared anywhere else and
specifically because i know all of you
who are watching this are doing video
you actually have a huge advantage over
a lot of the other people i teach who
aren't doing video because video is one
of the most important things that you
can use to show a product and show not
just like what it could do for somebody
but how it actually works and there's a
huge advantage that you have over others
so i'm gonna dive into the slides right
now so that we can go in and just get
started here so let's pick this up
and i think
here we go so this is income beyond ad
revenue and even even before you get
monetized on youtube you can use this
stuff even on day one so what i'm hoping
is that you'll come away with this
presentation with just some actionable
things that you could probably do even
in your next video or at least within
the next month and start to see some
revenue coming i also want to be honest
with you and just tell you you're not
going to be a millionaire overnight but
i have generated millions of dollars
through this over the years and these
things stack on each other as well
because you can actually have one video
perform and then it connects to another
video and these things can continue to
generate more income in all different
kinds of ways
so video creators get ready because
we're about to dive in also i just want
to just give a big shout out to the
entire think media team especially you
sean because you've been so supportive
of my work i was even at your event in
vegas which was just an absolute hit one
of my favorite events in a very long
time that i've been to just so many
amazing people i've gotten to know a lot
of great friends there vanessa lao and i
connected at that event and just the
amazing audience that showed up you just
put so much effort into everything that
you do to serve your audience and i just
want to say thank you and it was a lot
of fun because shawn and i got to take
some fun fancy photos together we even
did a fun little dance together which
was super fun we literally just worked
for like five minutes to learn the
stance and do it yeah
better but as we all know when you get
started with something for the first
time it's not always going to be great
but you have to be a disaster before you
become the master right we're going to
start off with this affiliate marketing
thing we're going to start from the
beginning here we're going to get into
some advanced stuff as well and i want
to start with well what is affiliate
marketing if you've never heard this
term before it can be a little bit
confusing can be a little bit
intimidating but what really it is it's
generating an income by recommending
other people's products right like you
might have your own products or might
want to create your own products in the
future and of course we all know what
advertising is but no this is you
essentially earning kind of a commission
as a result of pointing customers to
another company right so you have this
audience and you have viewers and you
have subscribers and fans and followers
and there are products out there that
they could potentially purchase it's you
being the connector between these two
things that allows this company to pay
you as sort of a thank you right you're
not asking your audience to pay more
than they would just so that you can get
something but it's this company thanking
you and giving you sort of like a
commission as a reward
now you might be wondering like pat
like why would a company pay
you when they could get those customers
themselves well the truth is they can't
this is the leverage that you have over
these companies because you especially
being a youtuber
you have an audience an audience that
they couldn't get in front of themselves
or it would cost a lot of money in order
to do so so they'd rather share that
money with a creator like you
two authority you have a presence you
have respect you have the ability to say
things and recommend things and people
will listen to you and of course that
comes along with trust as well now this
is different than a brand deal a brand
deal is a company paying you x number of
dollars you know hundreds maybe
sometimes thousands of dollars to
mention a product in a video in a
certain kind of way with a script or a
mid-roll in the middle of the video or
what have you right that's a brand deal
this is a little bit different this is
you getting a link from this company you
put that link into your video into the
description and any time
from now until as long as that video
still exists or you still have this
partnership with them you will earn a
commission and that's the cool thing
about this right you could make
unlimited amounts of money in this way
versus just a specific amount up front
and that's the big thing about affiliate
marketing in fact i found that i've made
way more with affiliate marketing than i
have with any brand deals or
sponsorships i've ever had right the
other benefits of affiliate marketing
are this you don't need to spend time to
create your own products these products
that people are buying or going to buy
already exist you just need to be the
connector between those products and the
customers that are out there and that is
your audience of course customer service
is entirely handled or mostly handled by
that company right so all you need to do
is send people through that link
and then everything else is taken care
of of course this is just banking on the
fact that hopefully they take good care
of those people and that there is good
customer service and that product is
doing what it should be doing which is
why selecting the right product is
really really important and we'll talk
about exactly the right kinds of things
that would make sense for you
in just a minute
next it's scalable whether it's one
person going through that link or a
hundred thousand people going through
that link
there's not really additional work on
your end that needs to be done
next it can work for all stages of
business whether you are the beginner
and you're in your first video you're
creating your first video you can do
affiliate marketing you don't need to
wait till you get to a thousand
subscribers and four thousand hours of
watch time you can do this right now and
it definitely works of course when you
have amassed a bigger audience or you've
tapped into browse and um
search and suggested traffic on youtube
in all different kinds of ways you can
create long-lasting partnerships this is
often overlooked and something that we
talk about a lot in my course which is a
lot of these brands that you're an
affiliate for they actually know how
important you are to their success to a
point where they are willing to
sometimes send you things for free right
sean you know this doing a lot of camera
reviews a lot of these companies will
send you stuff before anybody else can
get access to it so that you can review
it and do some stuff on youtube for it
like that's very common in the world of
youtube but you can also
leverage a higher commission you can
also leverage better deals for your
audience and you can create these
long-lasting partnerships so much in
fact that a lot of the companies that
i've been an affiliate for back in the
day i'm now an advisor to the company i
actually own shares of those companies
now as a result which is pretty cool and
it can become super passive you can
create these things once especially as a
video creator and they can continue to
work for you over time and you can get
started
right now so in this presentation again
this is a workshop whether you have your
notepads ready or you're going to come
back and watch this replay and also
shout out to the replay crew watching
this
here are the things that we're going to
discuss the biggest mistakes that newbie
affiliate marketers make and how to
avoid them
a five-point product test for high
converting product promotion we're gonna
talk about how to find the right
products and there's five things that
you need to pay attention to in order to
make it work and give you the best
chance of making the most money in a
genuine way number three specific video
strategies
this is what's cool is i've pulled from
my own youtube channel the videos that
have worked and why and i want to share
those with you so that you can replicate
the same results too
number four the affiliate marketers
secret weapon and i use this secret
weapon to make more money and get more
organic traffic as well
number five rules to keep in mind this
is illegal stuff so you don't get in
trouble or banned and throughout this
entire presentation you can check out
the cases the case studies and examples
and i want you to take them and use them
for yourself as well excuse me and if
you stick around to the end i also have
a free gift for you as well that you can
take home with you
all right here's the big promise
the big promise is not like i said
millions of dollars overnight yachts and
lamborghinis i mean although that could
potentially happen that's not what i'm
promising you what i'm promising you is
number one you're gonna have a better
understanding of this world of affiliate
marketing and understand what to promote
and how to promote them i want you to
promote things in a way where your
audience will actually thank you for
that that's the beauty of this is
everybody can win you can win because
you're getting a commission the product
company can win because they're getting
more customers and the customer's going
to win because you've pointed them to
the right product that's going to help
them and they will thank you for that
and that's great because you can get
paid and get thanked at the same time
number two you'll be able to potentially
generate people who've watched uh this
kind of stuff for me before
and who i teach in my courses within a
month they're often able to make an
additional 500 a month almost right off
the bat by implementing some of the
stuff now that obviously depends on
where you're at now and your your reach
and whatnot but i'm going to teach you
some stuff that's going to hopefully get
you there and you're going to understand
the affiliate marketing language to help
you get started a lot of what you're
going to see today is literally coming
straight out of my course and i wanted
to give it to you because
shawn is my friend and i wanted to help
out any friend of sean is a friend of
mine so you are my friend
a little bit about my story though if
you don't know who i am my name is pat
flynn i actually started out my first
online business in 2008 helping people
pass an architectural exam this is the
exam right here it's called the lead
exam and it's helping people with green
architecture i actually came from the
world of architecture got laid off in
2008 and i built my business helping
people pass this exam
now i had my own study guide that i
created and i sold it for 19.
in 95 cents you can see a banner for it
there at the top and that's how i
started making my money online for the
first at first was selling my own
product but then i started to realize
that there were other companies i could
work with and i worked with these other
companies in a very traditional kind of
way for example there's this company
green building education services who
had an exam that was online that you
could take a simulated exam that costs
80 bucks
and i worked with them in this way hey i
have a website i have traffic how would
you like to advertise on my website and
they said sure so they decided to pay me
a hundred dollars a month to have a
banner on my website and i thought i was
making out good like 100 bucks that i
didn't have before just to advertise on
my website cool that sounds good but
then i discovered this thing called
affiliate marketing and i discovered
that they had what they called a
referral program sometimes it's known as
a partner program so if you are a um
user of a product and they don't have an
affiliate program check out partner
programs or referral programs now they
didn't have this at the bottom of their
website like many companies and products
have i actually asked them and they said
yeah it's invite only but yeah we'd love
to have you be a part of it and i said
okay well what are the terms and they
said for every person that you send over
that becomes a customer will give you
22. 22 out of the 80. so you know pretty
good percentage about 30 commission
and i said okay well all i need to do is
send maybe five people through per month
and then i'll have you know surpass the
hundred dollars that i was making uh
doing the banner advertising the first
month
that i connected my affiliate link to my
website
i had over 150 people join
so 150
times 22 dollars was way more than the
100 i was making per month as just you
know a banner ad or a sponsored type of
situation so that was my first
introduction to affiliate marketing and
it changed the game for me
now it was at this point i started my
website that many people know me from
now which is called the smart passive
income blog this is what it looked like
back then it's changed a little bit it
looks a little bit nicer now but i
wanted to show you again you got to be a
disaster before you become the master
this is what it looked like messy start
but since 2008 i've generated
a load of amazing success as a result of
being there to help entrepreneurs
whether you're a video creator blogger
physical products digital products etc
spi smart passive income is there to
help you which is really exciting now i
have a youtube channel as well it's gone
through a number of different phases but
we're currently sitting at you know 350
plus
thousand subscribers over the years i've
learned a lot and most of those
subscribers came just in the last couple
years because i finally got my head on
straight learning from people like shawn
and whatnot what works and what doesn't
and so you're in the right spot but i
have a lot of videos that have done very
well to help entrepreneurs there i also
have another youtube channel in the
pokemon collection space
pokemon has just become a huge part of
my life since the pandemic and i started
a youtube channel because there were
some clear holes that i thought i could
fill and it's definitely been working we
just crossed 228 000 subscribers this
morning and i'm making money yes through
affiliate marketing and advertising and
sponsorships here on this channel as
well and it's less than two years old
which is incredible i have podcasts many
people know me for my podcast smart
passive income has seen over 65 million
total downloads and i've also authored
some books my first book let go my
second book will it fly which was a wall
street journal bestseller even as a
self-published book and my latest book
super fans which yes that is mr beast at
vidsummit
giving away my book uh so very very in
tune with the world of youtube and i'm
just so grateful that that happened
because that was really cool i also have
courses a lot again of what you're about
to see comes from my course one two
three affiliate marketing and then we
also have a community uh spi pro and
over the years you know these are all
different kinds of things that generate
income for me i've generated over seven
and a half million dollars in revenue
since 2008.
50 of that has come from affiliate
marketing
50 that is an insane number sean talked
about how affiliate marketing changed
his life it's definitely changed my life
as well and so we're just going to dive
right in if you're in the chat right now
and you're ready to get started hook me
up with your favorite emoji because we
are about to begin if you're excited
about diving in so sean are we ready to
dive in i know that you're kind of
letting me loose here but i just want to
check in
yeah it's amazing i'm so fired up my
favorite emoji emoji is the cross swords
i'm about to drop it and here we go yo
let's go uh fire emoji is my favorite
one so
let's dive in
the top two mistakes wannabe affiliate
marketers make people who attempt
affiliate marketing and they don't do it
very well this may be you right you
attempted this you've heard about it
you've promoted a few things here and
there but you just aren't getting some
good income from it the top two mistakes
are number one choosing the wrong
products to promote
this is the most important thing because
when you align the product to the
problems or the pains or the challenges
that your target audience has
well
a lot of it will happen automatically a
lot of the success will happen
automatically because that product is
perfectly aligned so we're gonna dive
into a five-point strategy to help you
pick the right products in just a minute
but that is definitely the biggest
mistake is choosing the raw on products
to promote if you are promoting products
because it has a good commission you're
doing it for the wrong reasons you have
to do it primarily first because it
solves a problem
and then it just so happens to also
offer you commissions on the back end as
well right whenever i've done anything
with thinking about how am i going to
make the most money first
it's usually been going down the wrong
road and it has not worked out for me
but whenever i think about how can i
serve first just like my shirt says it's
always worked out really really well so
that's that's how you find the right
product and number two dull promotional
strategies we think that just like one
review video is gonna do it for us no
we're going to talk about some
strategies and some intertwined web type
stuff that we're going to do
within our channels that are going to
help us maximize our efforts and see the
most revenue come in
so what kinds of things can you promote
as an affiliate well you can promote all
kinds of things physical products
digital products software coaching
programs uh services online courses
books events like all that kind of stuff
can be promoted as an affiliate you can
generate an income by recommending
things and that's really what affiliate
marketing is it's you cheering from your
place of knowledge from your place of
expertise and experience your
recommendations for things that can help
serve a person in some way shape or form
but all kinds of things can be promoted
as an affiliate
but here is the
process by which you're going to do it
correctly
step one we got to find the right
product and it always starts
with
the problem you've got to know the
problem or the pains of your target
audience if you don't know this
then none of the rest of this stuff will
matter you have to know what your
audience is going through so that you
can understand what products can serve
them through that right that's step
number one if you can define the problem
and oftentimes if you can actually
describe it even better than they can
they're gonna automatically assume that
you already have the solutions so when
you nail down not just what the problem
is but the language that your target
audience uses to describe that problem
you've done half the battle there and
now you can find products that relate to
that and when you find a product that
relates to that problem you have to be
able to know what's the promise of that
product i promise i mean what's the
transformation what's the outcome what's
the thing that's going to happen after
that product is used
nobody buys products because of the
product people buy products because of
what that product's going to do for them
right people don't buy online courses
because they don't wake up in the
morning and go oh i can't wait to buy an
online course today right they buy what
the result of that course is going to
give them right they buy their future
state
inside of that product whether it's a
physical product digital product
whatever the thing that they're going to
do with it is what they're looking
forward to buying not like the product
itself right so the better that you can
understand and relay what the promise of
that product is the better
now a person might see that you have
nailed down exactly what they're going
through they might also see this product
that you have in front of them that they
are like intrigued about but you know
what they're also going to say to
themselves well how do i know this is
actually going to work right they're
always going to say that themselves and
that's why a video creator benefits more
than anybody else when it comes to
helping with that objection because this
is where you can show proof you can show
people literally show people
with your videos proof that this thing
actually fulfills this promise right
that is the huge benefit that you as a
video creator have is showing that proof
if you if you leave out the proof when
you showcase these videos
then it's not going to work at all
now there's a additional source of proof
that will work even better and that's
your own personal experience when you
can bring in your own
challenges your own struggles and how
this product help you overcome them
then that's when you're going to get the
maximum
opportunity the maximum revenue right
it's not just proof that somebody else
it worked for somebody else but it's
proof that it worked for me and you
using your creative video elements and
your storytelling and your camera work
to be able to showcase that story
that's just that's just a recipe for
success right there and then finally on
top of that once you have the videos
published it's the promotional
strategies it's not just publishing the
video that's going to do it it's the way
you publish the video it's how you
campaign once that video is published
and again we're going to get into all of
those efforts today i promise you but i
wanted to give you this sort of
headspace stuff first because if you
don't nail the right product none of the
strategies matter at all in fact if you
nail the wrong product
and you have good strategy
i mean you're just gonna
faster ruin your reputation right if you
promote a product and it doesn't do what
it promised and it actually was promoted
because you're just in it for the
commissions and wanting to make money
eventually it catches up to you right
sure you might make a lot of money up
front but eventually people are going to
have a bad experience they're not going
to trust you they're going to move on we
don't want that to happen right
here's the ultimate strategy like the
one big takeaway from this the big
principle behind what makes this work is
i mean the big struggle is really it's
promoting other people's products it's
it's not your own product
but here's the secret you want to
promote these products that aren't yours
as if they were yours if you promoted
your own product you would take a lot
more time and effort
to showcase how beneficial this thing is
for your audience
right you wouldn't just do a video about
your own product and then move on you
would talk about it in depth you would
talk about it in different kinds of ways
you would show a lot more proof behind
it but yet when we promote other
people's or other companies products we
don't do that for some reason but you
should and this is what's going to help
you stand out from everybody else
creating the same old review videos
what's going to help you stand out from
the other creators who are also
promoting that same product they're
going to come to you because you're
telling people about it in all different
kinds of ways because you're treating it
as if it's your own product and imagine
a person asking asking you a question
about that product if you could answer
it as if it was your own they're gonna
have a lot more trust in you they're
gonna say you know what i believe you i
know that you've used this product it
shows and you're giving me some
direction here fantastic i'm in and
they're going to go through your link so
that you get credit for it and that
company will pay you as a result
now the starting point can be very
difficult this is especially helpful if
you're just starting out again if you're
a small creator you actually benefit
from the fact that you can do this right
up front even with your first video but
you might have a question like well
where do i even begin how do i know what
product to even promote there's two
things that you can do to help you
number one ask people what they are
already buying
if you have even 10 people in your
audience you can ask them the question
what was the latest purchase you made
that was so helpful to help you get to
your goal or help you toward that goal
they're going to tell you literally what
they're buying now those people have
already purchased the product but if
you're attracting people just like them
they might also benefit from a
recommendation for that same product as
well so this could be a very easy way
for your audience to just guide those
decisions for you my favorite thing to
do in business is to remove the
guesswork as much as possible the best
way to do that is to utilize the
audience that you have and if you don't
have access to an audience yet find
where those audiences exist and find out
where they're talking where are they
having discussions they're already
having these discussions about the
things that they're already buying that
are helpful they're already having
discussions about these problems and
pains and challenges that they're having
go find those discussions that are
happening in those groups in those
forums on those communities in social
media and you can better determine what
your next steps will be so asking people
what they're already buying is great
it's also a great way to start a
conversation with those companies
because you can say hey my audience is
already buying your product how can we
work together so i can get more of my
audience involved let's do let's let's
work out a partnership together or do
you have an affiliate program etc
number two this is a great one start
with the first step if you have an
audience and you know that they're going
on a journey to something
what is the first step in that journey
right with my audience for example with
smart passive income their journey was
building a business and a brand or a
personal brand to be able to build a
lifestyle business to be able to create
products online to be able to do
affiliate marketing but they're gonna
need a website to start that's one of
the first steps
so one of my first videos was this video
right here how to build a blog in less
than four minutes because i wanted them
to understand how to build a blog and so
of course i teach them how to do this
and within this video i show them
exactly
what product to use and how to use it i
demonstrate it i show proof and i show
proof that i actually use the same
hosting company and as a result this
video which is very poorly done it was
before i understood how to create a good
hook there's literally like 20 seconds
of music at the beginning of this video
which like is not the way you should do
it nowadays obviously but even still
this had 230 250 000 views this one
video showing people how to get a result
because of this is the first step that
they wanted to know about
has accounted for over
185 000 in earnings this just this one
video because it just it helps them
through that first step and it provides
value but also shares the tool that i
used along the way so again what is that
first step that your audience is going
to need to go through
showcase a video and if there happens to
be tools related to that that you can
promote as an affiliate interject them
in that and everybody will be happy
so pick the right products with step
number one
step number two is passive promotional
strategies what i love about passive
promotional strategies just like passive
income right you could set it up and it
will continue to work for you over time
number two it's the ultimate value first
strategy the way that i'm about to share
with you right you do these things it
actually shows that you are
of expertise that you have value to
share first you're giving first right if
the first interaction that you have with
your audience is a
give me type of interaction like a very
eu-centric interaction
then they're not going to be open to
these recommendations that you have but
if you're giving first if you're giving
them something and helping them
transform already
then the ask or the recommendation comes
with a lot more open-mindedness and
they're more likely to take advantage of
that offer that you're giving them so
it's the ultimate value first strategy
and then finally you can get organic
traffic through this as well so here's
how this works i'm just gonna show you
some videos that have worked really well
for me
phase one of this strategy
is what i like to call the ultimate
all of you or ever needs tutorial
so you create a tutorial that is so
in-depth that that in and of itself
could serve them right so in this case
this is an email marketing in 2022
workshop right it literally goes through
everything a person might need to know
with relation to email marketing
now in this video i teach strategies for
email marketing
but i happen to also use a tool in
particular
along the way and i mentioned that tool
throughout it's mentioned in the
description that tool is called
convertkit there's a lot of other great
email service providers but that's the
one i'm an affiliate for in this single
video with only 19 000 views it's not a
ton
has already accounted for over
3 000 in earnings
per month because it's a recurring
income revenue
some products pay you monthly so long as
a person stays that's sort of the holy
grail of passive income not all products
do that if you promote a microphone on
amazon for example people aren't you
know paying monthly to get access to
that microphone like they are for
certain software so you only get paid
one time but again those are still
important too because those are things
you're already talking about anyway and
they stack up over time but this one
video by going deep into the topic
and then mentioning the tools along the
way has served really really well here's
another example in fact this one's
performed even better this is a video i
published four years ago how to start a
podcast people know me for podcasting
and i said you know what
i'm gonna just teach everything
and guess what i also have a course
about podcasting and people still go and
pay for the more detailed stuff for
access to me for access to the community
so you might be like pat i don't want to
give everything away for free what you
can
and you can still have some paid things
on top of it so i just wanted to get
that out of the way but this is how to
start a podcast complete tutorial
equipment and software
1.4 million views
here
i talk about equipment like microphones
and of course i drop in my affiliate
link for that but i also include the
software and i include affiliate links
for that inside of these tutorials as
well i also include a link to the
podcast hosting provider that i offer
and partnered with in there as well plus
podcasting services like editing
services and management
all of these tools are mentioned in this
tutorial but people see this tutorial
and go oh my gosh you're giving this
away for free
this is incredible value
and everybody can win because they want
to go through the same steps that you do
your audience wants to go through the
same process you did if the end result
is where they want to go to so the end
result here is a podcast up on apple and
spotify and google podcast etc so people
follow the steps step 4 get hosting
where do i get it oh i'm going to take
pat's recommendation because he's given
all this free information for free are
we seeing how this works i want to make
sure we all follow now this video was
published four years ago and the beauty
of this
is just every couple years you can just
update it so here was the latest one
that was published six months ago
with literally the same kind of thing
promoting
the newer microphone that people should
get promoting the software the hosting
company which was the same as the
previous one and these videos have been
doing very very well now this is phase
one a tutorial style video in depth
about a topic that your audience
you know that they want to know about
and if you just so happen to have tools
that can help them along the way or help
speed up the process even better i did
one i don't have a screenshot for it
here but i also taught keyword research
a lot for search engine optimization
back in the day and so i did these very
in-depth keyword research tutorials and
i start i did it in this way you create
the
uh free way to do it
and then show the headache free way to
do it right so imagine a video tutorial
teaches you how to do keyword research
for free but it takes 15 minutes and
these spreadsheets and it just takes a
lot of time and effort
but you can do it for free using these
tools google gives you
or that's the free way to do it in the
same video that's how you do it for free
i'm providing value right or you can do
everything i just showed you in 15
minutes in 10 seconds using this tool
here
so now a person can go hey you just
created this video because you wanted to
make money no i gave you the free way to
do it
but now i'm also juxtapositioning
the freeway which is
hard and long with the headache-free way
people can clearly see the value of the
tool that i'm offering to do all that
stuff for for just such faster time that
they're going to click on that link
because you've given them value and
again everybody wins so again that's
that's the cool thing remember
freeway versus headache freeway in the
same video could be a great strategy for
you
so that's phase one the ultimate all of
you or might ever need kind of video
phase two
create a video optimized for each one of
those tools that you mentioned right
and the beauty of this is youtube can
recognize
that you're now starting to become an
authority in that space you didn't just
create the all-in-one tutorial you're
creating the little mini things that are
also related to that
so even without having to i mean you
obviously should in your description
point all these together like an
intertwined web you should point one uh
like one of your end screen
um
one of your end screen links should be
to your you know all in one or all you
need video you're from phase one
as you can see i have videos on
microphones that was a specific
moment in this bigger video but i go in
in even more depth
right best mics under 75 dollars what if
you're like a big question i often got
was well how do i record a podcast on
the go cool i created a video to answer
that question that then points back to
that main one and each of these as you
can see has 60 70 000 views and within
each of these
i have affiliate links for the
microphones i have affiliate links for
that rode uh portable microphone that
goes with the iphone et cetera
software check out how these ran
367 000
views
wow same number of views as number of
subs i just noticed that and then the
audacity one 593 000 views now with
these videos in particular yes i do talk
about the software here
these tools are free
so there is no affiliate commission that
comes from these
that's okay remember what i said earlier
create the content in the videos that
will support your audience and solve
their problems first if they happen to
include a tool with a commission awesome
does that mean if it doesn't include a
commission you shouldn't publish it no
way
you are here to provide value and so
these tools to talk these two tutorials
that you're seeing which are the
software components of podcasting
no they don't come with a commission but
you should still publish them anyway
because guess what people come in from
the audacity tutorial like the 600 000
views and then they go to the main the
main one that does have the affiliate
links in them right
you can see how they're all sort of
intertwined now here's one for hosting
188 000 views 105 000 views all
specifically about that one component of
the bigger picture which is the podcast
hosting
right and what happens when you do this
over time it doesn't happen overnight
but you're going to start to see all of
them rise together
all these videos in this one category
all based off of that all a person might
need video begin to rise and then you
begin to own that category that's
eventually what happens if you look up
podcasting it changes for every viewer
and it changes often uh because youtube
always moves the rankings around and
oftentimes i see sean in the think media
videos in there too i saw i know you
guys targeted podcasting and i see you
in there and you're doing the exact same
thing and i love it but as you can see
if you search podcasting i did this the
other day look i have three of the four
top videos on podcasting
which is which is crazy because now at
this point i can create the more browse
and the more suggested traffic type
videos right like watch this before
starting a podcast five things they
don't tell you very clickable title and
anyone looking for podcasting is now
going to click on that almost a half
million views since a year ago
50 podcast tips in 15 minutes
just published pretty recently it's
doing okay but again
i'm owning this space now on youtube and
you can own that space for you too
what happens when you do this this is
that podcasting tutorial these are the
analytics yes it's getting a lot of
views because a lot of those other
videos are pointing people toward it
right look at it's
look at youtube search on the right-hand
side as far as like um views go you
might think that
a majority of these views are coming
from search they're not they're actually
coming from suggested videos that is
from my other videos and other people's
videos on the channel as well
and there are some uh there's there is
some traffic coming from my own website
too
but look at the estimated revenue seven
thousand from ad revenue that's youtube
ad revenue
this video the single video has
accounted for
or this single strategy not just this
video but all those videos together
intertwined like i said has accounted
for five to six thousand dollars in
earnings from affiliate revenue
per month
this is earning
way more
than the youtube ad revenue
all these things combined again because
a lot of this stuff does have recurring
income
is
providing a massive massive reliable
income um
so it's not just about the video
remember i said the worst thing you can
do is create one review video and call
it quits no
you need to treat these things like they
are your own products and then you can
take ownership of that space on youtube
and actually
you know think media has done a really
good job of this with relation to a lot
of video related things it's again been
interesting sean to see creep into
myspace a little bit now we're like you
know but it's okay it's okay because
it's all it's all forcing me to think
about okay how can i create better
content and that's ultimately what's
best for the audience right so i love
that
and that's that's it's just
it's just performing way better than
just the ad revenue alone the affiliate
earnings on top of that is what's what's
driving it it's it's just so neat
step three so that was passive because
those are those videos are doing work
for me now like as we speak people are
finding them and it's doing the work for
me and i'm gonna see more commission
come in tomorrow as a result of that
right now active promotional strategies
are a little bit different these are
ones that are usually time based like a
thing is going to happen an event is
going to happen at a certain time but
you can use these things to create a lot
more excitement sort of you know a lot
of hype and excitement around a specific
time period it does take a lot more time
to do but you can often get better
results and i want to give you an
example of this it's not video specific
but imagine how you can use this in your
video channel um this is uh what i like
to call the small win challenge
challenges are absolutely a fantastic
way to mobilize your audience to not
just get things done and get results but
also lead into an affiliate offer so
this relates to my email affiliate
partnership with convertkit and i'll
show you how so we have a challenge it's
a free challenge you can do this on a
video you can do this with live streams
on your videos or or on a separate email
list that you might have built over time
but we run these challenges and they
work really really well this is a 0 to
100 email subscriber challenge in three
days so in 72 hours if you take this
challenge again free you'll have
hopefully a hundred email subscribers
not a thousand not ten thousand why
because that seems so out of reach it
needs to be a small
win within a small time period that a
person can dedicate to it so here's what
happens
we're providing a small challenge
related to their first step right they
want to get started with email marketing
cool here's your first step let's get
100 emails
the affiliate product naturally fits as
step number two so the way that this
challenge works is you go to
100emails.com
you get an email sent to you
one uh like when we first did this it
was live now it's been automated but the
first one we had 14 000 people
participate
and it ran between
a 72-hour period on the calendar that
everybody started at the same time
everybody ended at the same time that's
why there was a lot of hype for there
was a facebook group to go along with it
and all this stuff day one they all get
sent an email just an email nothing else
they just get a send an email with their
first steps
day two they get the two steps day three
they get day three steps and that's
challenge
day four is where this number two point
comes in day four was like hey
congratulations you got a 100 emails
some people got a thousand some people
only got 50 but still they did more than
they ever did before
and day four
says hey now your next steps are the
following you need to get an email
service provider to put all these emails
into so you can start sending broadcasts
and start to collect more emails on your
website so here's what i recommend i
recommend using convertkit here's the
link for it et cetera et cetera et
cetera so that's how we led from this
challenge
we help them get a quick win a result
something that they've never gotten
before into now what the product is
right so you can imagine this product
that you find that you want to promote
what might be a little tiny step before
that that can open up their eyes and
vision too than getting access to that
product and using it for themselves
this has worked
so well and this is accounted for over
i don't even know what the number is but
it's definitely accounted for you know
over six figures in earnings since we
began this challenge a number of years
ago which is just incredible uh and then
number three the challenge is cool too
because people can share the challenge
with each other it can spread virally
which is really amazing
another thing another thing that has
worked um i know i don't do this
personally but i know a number of people
who have i should be doing this but i
just wanted to share with you because
you might have an opportunity to do this
right now if you have a video that's
providing you some affiliate revenue
already
right
and different products will pay you
different amounts so you know you want
to do this with a product that's serving
you really really well
you can take some of those earnings
put it into a youtube ad
campaign
that gets you more views on that video
and this becomes this beautiful machine
i know two or three people who are
making over six figures just doing this
they find a video that works not all of
them work but they find a video that
works it pays them well from those
affiliated commissions they then take
some of that money that they got from
commissions and put it into ads
so that more people can watch that video
who would who just aren't able to find
them through search or through browser
or suggested and so now this machine
comes because now those viewers who come
in from those ads are now watching those
videos paying for those products and
you're getting more commission and this
can just continue to cycle through and
grow bigger and bigger
so that's what we like to call the
machine all right now on to the
affiliate marketer's secret weapon
now
the secret weapon is yes using video but
a very specific kind of video and that
is the demo video
not a review
a demo a demonstration of how the
product is used and the reason why this
works so well is because
people use youtube to see things before
they buy them
right people want to see what it's going
to be like before they spend their money
and this can be done with digital
products it can be done with physical
products on the left i have a convertkit
demo where i show people how to use
convertigate again it's not even a
review it's hey let me show you how this
works once you get it
and with the microphones on the
right-hand side for physical products
all of my highest converting campaigns
use demo videos on youtube to support
them
works for all different kinds of
products digital physical courses etc
and number three can help you get
organic traffic as well so not only are
you getting an affiliate commission from
this not only has it become a very great
resource that you can use in courses
inside of your website inside of other
playlists that you might have right
because these things hey i mentioned
convertkit on my email list cool here's
a video showing you exactly what it's
like once you get it there it is it's a
perfect resource visual that can help
people with their decision
but here are some tips number one find
other videos about that product
and create a better one
that's it and you know what it what it
what that means uh creative a better
title and thumbnail create a better hook
at the beginning of the video sean is a
master of hooking people so definitely
pay attention and get inspiration from
him
make yours better help people stick
around longer and your video will now
surpass the others it'll get suggested
more it'll also surpass them in search
eventually
number two show off how simple it is to
use this is what people want the big
mistake a lot of people do with reviews
like if i'm reviewing this k2 kikron
keyboard
the bad demo video would be one that
goes into
literally every single feature now this
keyboard has a lot of features right and
i could talk probably for 30 or 40
minutes about this but again part of
this is to excite people enough to want
to go and buy it this is not an
instruction manual that's the big
difference here of the demo i want to
show two or three things
that are just awesome about this and
maybe even share a couple things that i
think could be done better or how i
would improve it right this is what
people want i people want to see how
simple this is to use when you start
getting into all right now a secret here
is if you do these seven different
things this unlocks for you it opens up
that's too much already that can be a
separate video that can be used to
provide more value to people who've
already purchased it this is for people
who you want to click on those links
two or three things
that show them how easy it is to use
just two or three things that may be the
most mind-blowing things or the things
that most relate to the challenge or
problem or maybe you've had enough
experience with this product that you
know that there's um you know a big you
know learning curve up front you can
help them get over that right and then
two or three things show them how easy
it is to use and now they're going to be
excited they're they're mirror neurons
if you want to get into psychology in
neural uh neuroscience
people have
mirror neurons in their brain that when
they see somebody else doing something
that excites them they go they want to
go and do that thing too
so we're taking an advantage of that
here two or three things with that
product that make them go oh i want that
too and now they're going to click on
your link to go and get it
number three obviously you want to
publish on youtube yes you want to
optimize it but you can optimize it
either and yes you can have both but i
prefer when i create a video to either
optimize it for search
so i have keywords and the name of that
product there and in the thumbnail if
you have the name of the product in the
title you also want to include the logo
of that item in the thumbnail because
that's the story you're telling people
when they search for that thing they
find that thing they see that thing now
they click that thing right
now if i'm optimizing for browse or
suggested which has much bigger
opportunity then i'm going to have a
title that doesn't even necessarily
mention the name of that tool but it
relates to the specific problem or
or or curiosity that a person might have
so that they click on it right and the
thumb and the thumbnail will sort of
support that
so here's an example
so i am an affiliate for a product
called the script the script is really
cool it's a cool editing program the
neat thing about it is i can record a
video or audio and if i want to edit my
audio or video i can just use the
automatically generated transcript i can
highlight the part of the the transcript
that i want to get uh get rid of
hit delete and it automatically edits
that audio or video for you right i can
edit using the transcript which is
pretty crazy they also have this pro
tool
called overdub and what overdub does is
i can record my voice
for a certain number of minutes
and the ai the automated
artificial intelligence i was like what
does ai stand for uh the the tool will
learn my voice and let's say i record a
podcast episode and i forgot to say
something like uh like a like a date or
something
i can
type into the transcript that date
and the tool will read it as my voice
it's kind of mind-blowing and very scary
and i was like you know what i want to
highlight this tool and and those
features about it i think this is really
neat so i created a couple videos to
support me wanting to introduce this
tool but also wanting to take advantage
of that i am an affiliate for this so
here was video number one this new audio
and video editor is a game changer
auto transcriptions and screen recording
too
so
this is a browse and ho uh
and and home
uh sort of based
video right it doesn't mention descript
at all it doesn't even have the logo in
it but this is because i wanted to
capture people's attention a lot of my
audience knows me for podcast editing so
i thought this would capture their
attention and it has
47 000 views this was published nine
months ago and people watch it and it
introduces them to this tool and then
they click on it to become a user and
then i get a commission
now i created a second video i wanted to
really
showcase this overdub tool now i could
have said the scripts overdub tool is
amazing or wow overdub changes
or overdubs ai you know
copied my voice but i was like you know
what
i've been doing youtube for a while we
need to really capture people's
attention here and i'm not even going to
mention overdub that people who've never
seen or heard of that that's a wasted
word how can i get people to click on a
video about this really cool audio sort
of voice
copying tool and get them interested in
descript well here is the video
this audio editing tool deep faked my
voice
with eye emojis
actually useful or scary this was the
second video i published just a week
later and look how many views it has
one million views
in just nine months
and the thumbnail tells a story
with that title right this is this is
what we're learning about titles and
thumbnails how they need to play with
each other in some way as you can see
it's like oh like i'm reacting in a way
like it's almost scary it copied my
voice you don't even need to know
exactly what those things are on the
screen it's like it makes you go what
i need to click on this and when when
this plays it just demonstrates this up
front and then i show people how to use
it i talk about the tool i talk about
descript
this has accounted since nine months ago
for several commissions
into dscript
and it's actually
as of june 2021 this has increased since
then obviously 12
dollars and fifty six cents in
commissions
simply from creating a couple videos and
being smart about the approach with them
again those two videos were a suggested
and browse approach because i didn't
include the title of that video i am now
this month creating videos specifically
about the script so that when a person
searches for the script they find my
video and they they see the the logo of
the script and they want to click on it
to learn more and this is how i'm going
to hopefully own the descript
space inside of youtube because a lot of
people are now catching on to this tool
and how this is how i want to get in
front of this is one tool
in nine months has generated twelve
thousand dollars
imagine doing this with other tools as
well you can do this and the cool thing
about this is you don't need subscribers
most 95
actually probably 99 of the viewers of
these videos are not subscribers i hope
that's encouraging for you right because
the subscribership we all get so worried
about how many subscribers we have
i would worry more about how do we get
more people who don't know who i am to
find my videos and when you understand
that then you know not to start your
videos with hey it's pat here welcome
back to the channel you get right into
the thing that they clicked on for and
then you earned the right to be able to
introduce yourself and get that
subscriber remember people are
subscribing to you not because of the
video they just watched
they're subscribing because of the
videos that they know or are hopefully
going to come from you and into their
home feed next right a big mental shift
there that really changes the game for
me as well anyway just getting a little
sidetracked here
the
legalities of this is really important
too right we're closing in on the end
here but this is really important it's
going to go really quick i'm not a
lawyer by the way but just keep this in
mind when you are doing affiliate
marketing you must disclose the
affiliate relationship that you have
with the company
you you must do that and even if you're
outside of the u.s you likely have even
more strict rules than we do in the u.s
this is across all platforms including
social media and a note at the bottom of
your website or something that says
affiliate disclaimer click here is not
going to work at the moment at which you
share something that is an affiliate
link you have to disclose that affiliate
relationship
you just have to now it actually is
actually helpful because if you are
providing value like in the way that i
taught you people are going to look for
your affiliate links to want to repay
you for all that free incredible
information
that you are giving them
now if you're promoting items on amazon
right this is a little bit
different because they have specific
rules you must disclose the affiliate
relationship just like i told you with
the other one
but you are not allowed to create links
and emails and you're not allowed to put
links and ebooks i had my account banned
for doing that i learned the hard way
links on social media and youtube are
okay but again when you mention that uh
affiliate link
also mention it in the description that
there is an affiliate relationship there
now the way to get around this is to
send people to a video instead of just
putting that link in in your email or in
an ebook have a video resource like a
demo video like i just said point people
towards that and that's where those
links and those disclosures are
um and yep you have to let people know
that they're going to amazon from your
website so
two questions for you
and i just want to just see in the chat
really quick what was the most valuable
piece of information that you picked up
today
right
and the second follow-up question is
well how valuable is actually that piece
of content if you never put it into
action i hope that with what we learned
here today you could take away something
that you can already start implementing
right and hopefully this inspires you to
get started on this journey to create
these these these separate videos that
can all intertwine with each other to
own these particular spaces that you
have some videos in on youtube and uh
sean with your permission and with
everybody else's permission i'd love to
share a little bit about that course you
mentioned earlier in case you want to go
further with me because affiliate
marketing is my game i've taught this to
thousands of people people's lives have
been changed from from the efforts that
i've
shared with uh here today and and and a
lot of the further stuff i talk about so
sean do you mind if i talk a little bit
about the course and then we can get
into um you know i can stick around for
some questions and such as well
cool
awesome i can't hear but i'm gonna
assume that's a yes
so um
this course actually let me let me get
off screen here just in case
okay we're good i'm in the show good to
go pat okay cool
thank you uh so let me go back and share
the screen and again thank you all for
for watching this i know i talked a lot
i had a energy drink right before this
so i probably had way too much uh but
let me share a screen one more time with
you and we'll get into uh the course
so
my course is called one two three
affiliate marketing and it's one two
three affiliate marketing because it's
literally step by step do these things
find the right product here's how you
connect with the company here's how you
get the affiliate link here's where to
put it here are the campaigns you can do
both passive and active to make this
happen in fact one of my favorite parts
about the course is we have a recipe
book so if you have for example a book
that you want to promote as an affiliate
cool go into the recipe book
under books and find the recipe to
promote those books
for example this is a recipe called the
webinar version 1 selling through
teaching if you're going to be promoting
a software you can use a webinar to
promote that software and also earn an
affiliate commission here's what just
like a recipe book here's what you need
here's how to execute it and here's what
you're going to do and in fact if you
want this one right here because you
being a video creator can do webinars
very very well
uh you already have video experience um
you can download this recipe here
smartpassiveincome.com recipe that's
that's just for you and with each of
these different strategies there's a
different effectiveness difficulty right
time to use it all that kind of stuff so
this is again if you are going to be
ever promoting a software and you want
to do it in a high value way using a
webinar this is a great way to do it and
that's where you can get the recipe
smartpassiveincome.com recipe now just a
couple testimonials just to show you
proof again that this is a course that
has really really helped people this is
william beam
and he said you know i'm very selective
about online courses i purchased mostly
because i'm just not sure about the
value i'll receive in return uh he has
been able to not just make up for the
cost but also to turn a profit as a
result of his investment inside of one
two three affiliate marketing this is
prairia who's a copywriter who
already knows how to write good copy but
still said that there's a ton of value
in here and she's learned to pick uh
she's picked up a couple things here and
there to write even better copy with how
to do affiliate marketing property uh
properly and um increase her revenue as
well uh here are just a lot more
testimonials from people receiving their
first commissions as a result of this
and so
i want to invite you into a special
promotion if you go to thinkpat
flynn.com you'll get access to 123
affiliate marketing for life you'll also
get access to the recipe book so that
you can just literally copy exactly what
to do you'll get access to weekly office
hours with me i host office hours every
single week for my students so that you
can ask a question and move on or even
stick around and join the community if
you want you'll also get access to a
community spi academy and this is a
special offer for think media followers
only
usually this course is 699 dollars
that's how much this course is offered
on our website but not for you because
sean and i are friends because i want to
help you out and i know affiliate
marketing can help you this is only 499
dollars today so if you go to thinkpat
flynn.com you'll see the sales page you
can get access to that the uh discount
is already applied to that particular
page the special page you'll even see
pictures of sean and i on there think
patlin.com and you'll also notice that
there are a couple bonuses that will be
offered as well bonus number one coming
in from sean is just and again sean this
was just so generous of you uh bonus
number one was this one here the youtube
starter kit which comes with a number of
different things that you've already
offered to your audience just all
packaged together in a kit including
title formulas the clarity blueprint
jump starting channel
video ideas money making video ideas
equipment tutorials and even thumbnail
training which i find to be the most
valuable thing uh and where you can get
a lot of upside on youtube nowadays um
632 dollars in total value just included
for free
uh when you purchase one two three
affiliate marketing and bonus number two
is sean's personal branding master class
where he walks you step by step through
what it takes to build a personal brand
which obviously shawn has done so well
and is the master of this um and if
that's of interest to you this will be
here as well and that's a actually
bigger value in 997
dollar total value so what happens is
when you go through think
pat flynn you'll also get immediately
after purchase a link to go here to
clean your free bonuses right away uh
you don't have to wait 30 days for that
you can get access to them right away
and this link to this page is available
after purchase i also want to offer you
the win with flynn guarantee so there is
a 30 day money back guarantee if you get
access to the course and you're like pat
this isn't for me or isn't what i
thought
um you know that's my fault and you'll
be able to with no questions asked get
your money back um i'm confident though
that this this will be able to support
you and help you out so here's all you
get for just 499 200 off the regular
price if you go to thinkpat flynn.com
you get access to the starter kit the
branding master class the guarantee the
community the office hours with me the
recipe book and the affiliate marketing
course uh obviously
it's a lot of stuff and again uh this is
available for you right now and we'd
love to join have you in there uh and
and even if it's not
for you right now um
you know just i want you to know that
there is a lot of opportunity on youtube
right now and it just takes one or two
of these things to really help you get
to that point where not only is it gonna
just pay you back already but you can
literally like with sean in his journey
affiliate marketing can absolutely
change your life and just unlocking a
few doors here and there with
partnerships that can help you
can can put you in a new trajectory with
your youtube success even before
monetization at a thousand subs and four
thousand hours of watch time so uh again
thank you so so much for having me today
and sean i hope that was helpful uh some
stuff that you've probably never even
seen before in there what do you think
man it was amazing uh pat we just got
such powerful feedback from people
here's a question what was your aha
moment uh today we love taking action so
drop
an aha moment uh something you want to
do an idea that you learned
pat it was so powerful to see your video
strategies um pretty high level to think
about the paid ad strategy back to
affiliate programs but i also loved how
you just shared so many things for if
we're just getting started we feel kind
of overwhelmed if you're if you have a
question actually about pat's uh course
the the website is on the screen so uh
there's you can see all the details and
everything broke down there but i also
have some questions that have been
coming in we'll get to as many questions
as we'll as we can here put four
question marks before and after and then
we're also uh doing today's training in
what's called our inner circle program
and so just a second i'll be doing hot
seats in q a probably about 15 minutes
so we'll just kind of rapid fire some uh
q a here uh but pat
uh thank you for adding so much value
massive uh aha moments coming in
and uh
let's start crushing some questions the
coral reef talk says is it a good idea
to have affiliate links in the
description of every video i just
released an amazon prime video two days
ago and i see i see clicks but not
conversions it may just take time what
is your thought youtube descriptions and
affiliate links yeah you definitely
should have
the
uh affiliate links in the description
but
what's most important is in the video
you are able to sell this thing that and
that that is clickable right so it's
really important that you have not just
affiliate links you know a lot of uh
youtube creators will have uh you know
these descriptions that are the same for
every video that are just i think it's
inside of youtube settings you can have
like a default
um
signature if you will for your uh
your video descriptions and they'll
often include like hey get my favorite
microphone here here's my favorite
camera that's totally okay to do
absolutely but because you're not
necessarily talking about that directly
in a video it's gonna be tough to get
conversions on that but you get one here
and there and it's it's worth doing
anyway because a lot of people have
questions about those kinds of things
but if you do create a video about a
particular thing and you mention that
link in the video and you also have it
in the description but you aren't seeing
a ton of clicks then we have to ask
ourselves well why aren't we getting a
ton of clicks or why aren't we getting a
ton of conversions if you are getting a
lot of clicks that's good that's like
step one if you aren't getting a lot of
clicks then we need to understand why
and it's a positioning messaging problem
but if people aren't converting it might
just be they have some questions to ask
so what you might be able to do is go
live to be there to support and add
answer questions or at least in your
community or in a community post see
what questions might be coming up
related to that because all it takes is
one objection to just stop everybody
from coming in right so they might have
some questions at which point they're
not quite ready to purchase but if you
answer those questions properly in a
follow-up video or even in a community
post that can unlock the ability for
them to now in the second touch point or
third touch point or on social media or
where what have you uh to follow through
and convert but yes definitely have the
links in description just make sure you
disclose that affiliate relationship
um one of the biggest questions we get
by the way if you're getting value out
of today's free master class can you
smash the like button maybe let somebody
know about uh all this value here
especially in these interesting times
we're living in man i couldn't recommend
starting a side hustle building side
income you know starting to put content
out there starting to build your
personal brand and starting to create
extra streams of revenue and so so much
information here and then of course if
you want to go to thinkpat flynn.com as
well you could see uh deeper dive
training and pat's community and all
that stuff there but this question comes
in a lot pat and i'm curious your take
and it's really like how big do i need
to be before i start justin asked how
many subs should i have before i start
affiliate marketing i know you teach
this it's not just a youtube thing too
it could be an email list size or social
media following size so break down your
thoughts on uh when to start when to
apply for the programs things like that
so imagine that you have a target
audience as we all should right and you
know that they have challenges or
problems or pains that they're going
through and you found a solution you
have a product that you know would help
them imagine you talk to somebody and
like pat i need help i know you have a
solution and you say
you know what i would share it with you
but i don't have enough followers yet
or you say you know what i you know my
brain's not big enough for me to share
it with you yet would you do that in
real life
no way right you would absolutely even
if it was just a single person go oh
yeah i know what can help you here it is
you don't have to worry about getting to
a certain point before you could start
you should start right now because there
are people out there who need a person
like you in your way with your expertise
with your experience to share something
and yes there are other people sharing
the same products but different people
resonate with different people and you
have a certain
group right your vibe attracts your
tribe and they're out there and they're
waiting for a person like you with
experience who's gone through something
similar to share a product that can help
them fast forward themselves or get that
transformation that they've been looking
for
you absolutely don't need
you could start from day one with zero
subscribers and still make money because
that's what you need to do you need to
serve people and you don't need a
certain number of people to be able to
do that and one of the objections is
though is what what if i don't get
approved for the program yet though um
if i'm doing the application of course
you teach different sas products it
could be an email software and and
you've got to apply for the affiliate
program on amazon what it typically is
is you actually apply a lot of times
they'll approve you but you have to make
qualified sales within a certain number
of days so do you encourage people to
have momentum so they can stay qualified
for it or any kind of any thoughts like
literally when to fill out the
application
yeah i mean you could
you can create a video and get no sales
but i would i was i would use that as
encouragement to okay how can i create a
better video the next time so that i do
create sales and that way you can
actually be encouraged to reapply you
can always reapply to the amazon program
and even if you don't get in there are
other things that you could promote and
i would still create videos about that
product even if you aren't getting a
commission because that is the right
thing to do
right and then you come out with a
following video because when you do that
your your audience is going to continue
to grow and eventually you'll get to
that point when you focus on service
first
where amazon will approve you and
everything will sort of unlock for you
so that that's the approach i would take
as far as like specifically when to
apply um i would i would just apply asap
and use that as light under the fire
fire under the light fight under your
butt whatever it is i would use that as
encouragement to go okay i gotta make
these videos great and again you don't
need any subscribers in order for a
video to pop off and do really well and
encourage your audience right so um i
think that that's the approach that i
would take sean what do you think nope
beautiful i love it now this is an
interesting question from find my film
what is your take on can we order
products again and again from amazon
review them and then return them
you know i'm not going to
say that i know the legal answer to that
but i mean honestly the approach i would
take would be
become known
in a particular space to a point where
these companies are going to send you
these products before you even ask them
right that's eventually where you want
to go now eventually you're going to
need to start somewhere and if nobody
knows who you are yet if you haven't
done enough video to sort of share an
expertise or or define your space inside
so in a niche yet then that's going to
be very difficult
honestly
i wouldn't approach it with the idea
that i'm going to return them i would
actually
try to build a relationship with that
company first so that they'll send it to
you which is possible even if you don't
have an audience yet they like you can
be persistent enough or you can show the
professionalism that you'll have with
supporting their thing and many of these
companies will send you loaners that's
another thing you don't have to go
through amazon and go through a return
thing and yes i know amazon has a really
good return policy i
personally would feel disingenuous
doing that because i know that i'd be
using
them in a way that probably wasn't the
way it was meant to be used um again i
would i would come with the approach of
how can i create enough to a point where
a company is going to want to send me
stuff and i'll have to you know be more
likely to turn them away because i'm
getting so much stuff right um
so yeah that that is an interesting take
i would start with products that maybe
you already have so you don't have to go
through that process or borrow products
from other people um you might get a
loaner from a friend or uh and you can
actually ask them about their experience
and record a little bit about that to
add a little bit more flavor to the
story that you're telling
all right niche lightning round uh peter
on a poll does affiliate marketing work
with a sports channel any brainstormed
ideas if someone's got uh talking about
sports yeah it depends on the way that
you're talking about sports right if you
are doing commentary on certain things
like
scores and stuff it's gonna be a little
bit more difficult because those things
don't relate to the
you know specific item that you're
sharing however i know that i follow a
number of sports
channels um i for a very long time was
doing a lot of basketball uh and i
bought a lot of things from different
people who were talking about in and
doing training i remember buying gloves
that were like had some weights and they
were like
not they were like slick so that the
ball sort of slides off and i can have
better control i spent like 75 bucks on
those things but it was because a person
i trusted recommended them um and i
bought certain balls that had like
bluetooth on them so i could see what my
shot percentages were and all that kind
of stuff
kind of kind of crazy what what power
an influencer has and you can be that
influencer lately i've been spending a
lot of money on fishing lures because
i've been doing a lot of bass fishing uh
i've been falling in love again with
with fishing and following a lot of
channels and of course
i want more bass that's my goal they
tell me which lure is going to catch me
more bass and guess what i click on
their affiliate links and they get paid
and i get a lure and hopefully catch a
fish um so again it depends on the kind
of sports channel or what it is you're
saying but i would i would promote
products where that obviously aligns
with your audience and if even if it's
not a direct thing um you know you could
test you could see how an audience would
respond to it or even talk to people
individually to see how they might react
if you were to promote something
second niche the colorado whiskey guys
suggestions for alcohol-based content
some of the things that i've seen
is there are um there are like obviously
alcohol has limitations in the
viewership and sometimes you know if you
go to a website it's like are you 21 or
over so youtube might have some
limitations in the distribution of the
videos but nevertheless
there's i always like to think about is
there subscription boxes in my niche
like subscribe there's geek box nerd box
different ones like that and that would
be maybe relevant for even pat's pokemon
channel the audience would be into it in
this case there's there are ones that
have different glassware different smoky
things you could add to the whiskey
there's different things or even
complementary things that would pair
with alcohol and food so there's there
could be affiliate things related to
that but there's been some people in
some of our youtube training and courses
that are in the alcohol niche and they
will do it's like glassware accessories
cocktail accessories and and kind of
like the ancillary things that may be um
not the direct
you in some cases you can't probably do
a an affiliate promotion or even sell
the alcohol online in that particular
case pat any thoughts on that
yeah i agree with you on that a lot of
the accessories and such i've personally
purchased some specific things to create
ice cubes for the whiskey that i have at
home um i'm more of a japanese whiskey
guy by the way we should chat um but uh
like let's get creative here you know i
know that eventually i'm gonna be
wanting to go to japan to go on a
japanese whiskey tour
and i'm going to need to go somewhere to
find recommendations for what are the
best tours what if you stepped up and
said you know what i'm going to create a
resource on my website or some videos
where i'm going to go to these
whiskey tours and i'm going to work with
these companies and i'll be an affiliate
for them and anybody who comes through
my link and goes on one of those tours
they're going to hook me up with
something like whether it's a commission
or a free product or what have you so
that could be an interesting way to do
it
also collect an email list when you
build an email list you have a lot more
control on the kinds of things that you
can do there and obviously i would also
connect with an attorney or some
professional who can make sure that you
are in alignment with the things that
you should be doing with relation to
that because that is you know a
specialty topic that does require some
other things that you know you want to
keep your safe for so um for yourself
safe for so yeah uh you can get creative
a lot of these things and just think of
all the things that you're interested in
make a list of them and you might be
able to find some interesting uh
partnerships that maybe weren't there on
the surface
man we're crushing the niches we got
jose any suggestions for personal
finance and crypto channel i always like
to ask about software personal finance
is huge you can be an affiliate for
like these uh crypto trading sites
although there's some drama in this
during this crypto winter there some of
them are shutting down but you've got uh
a lot of it's very lucrative to be
inside of apps
and or crypto trading stock trading
sites
um what do you think about personal
finance and crypto
yeah this actually brings up a topic
that i think is really important you
know let's take um crypto for example
there's a lot of different tools that
you could use for crypto there's
um crypto.com there's coin base and
like several others um
you could take the approach of hey i'm
going to create resources to
compare and show all these things
against each other and you know a lot of
people do that already and then they
have links to specifically join those
platforms and that's one way that you
can
generate a commission i know a lot of
youtubers who work with these companies
and have them as brand sponsorships as
well
um but
it's the idea of do you
recommend a tool
do you recommend
multiple different solutions for a
problem or do you step up and pick one
of them and have that be your primary
sort of go-to right so i have for
example i have uh
many different email service providers
that i could actually promote as an
affiliate and some of which could make
me more money than with my convertkit
one which is my main one
but
when you understand that you are going
to be playing expert curator when you
are a curator that is of service to your
audience and you could get paid for that
from the level of service that you're
stepping up to help sort of like remove
all the noise out there for people when
you like the the approach of saying you
know what hey there's a lot of tools
that you could use out there
this is the one i recommend
you're saving people time you're making
sure that people don't have to waste
their time doing research because you've
already done that research to go hey
this is the tool that you should use for
this
here's my link and here's how to use it
here are all the videos about it and
guess what that company is going to
notice that eventually to notice that
you picked their product over the others
because when you start playing like
reviewer
you can't really get into as much depth
and you can't
as easily develop these relationships
because you're trying to be buddy-buddy
with everybody versus hey i chose this
one crypto tool this is what i recommend
and then you create a nice relationship
with them they're going to hook you up
and you'll be able to create some unique
partnership deals and things from there
so that that's what i would do um
so again
one of those cases of share what you do
and the tools that you use to do it and
it doesn't even have to be about the
tools people just see you using those
tools they want to use the same tools
because they want to get the same
results as you
right it's like the difference of sean
creating a review video for a particular
camera
versus teaching this really high level
um program about how to create amazing
photography he just happens to use the
camera that is you know there in his
hands all the time people want to use
that same camera they'll actually ask
what camera to use i want to get that
same thing and it just becomes a very
high value um serve first approach to
the content that you create
man pat flynn you're just dropping the
fire today and want to thank you for all
the value also uh if you're watching
this i want you to know that uh when you
go to thinkpat flynn.com if you're
wondering what do i do next
if you go to thinkpat flynn.com you can
see this special offer that pat put
together uh for our community and so you
can see the discount is already applied
this is pat's
course on affiliate marketing i'm sure
you have a lot more questions um and 123
affiliate marketing it's where it's at
you can actually see the entire course
outline here so i recommend checking it
out to see what am i going to learn what
are all the details what is inside of
here and then as a reminder
um
we're also including a couple extra
bonuses that are no extra charge uh to
you obviously pat's course is already
immensely valuable at the full price
he's already given a discount but we're
throwing in our youtube starter kit and
our personal branding master class now i
wanted to give you just a little bit of
value on that because you know
this is worth writing down what makes up
your personal brand your unique point of
view what makes up your personal brand
your personality your process your
expertise your values and beliefs your
ideas your reputation your personal
stories and your purpose and your
mission
and one of the ways to supercharge
affiliate marketing
is by powering up your personal brand
you know the thing is uh the reason why
i trust pat flynn is because i trust pat
flynn because he has built a reputation
online he's consistently educated and
now added value he's world-class in his
content then when you meet him in a q a
or you meet him on a live stream or you
meet him at an event or you meet him and
then when you read a book like you're
consistently building your reputation
well how do you build a personal brand
just as extra value i wanted to include
my master class in this because the key
to really deeper than a tactic with
affiliate marketing is building real
trust is building a reputation online
where people trust you they get to know
you and as you become more known and
build your authority and become
established as an authority in your
niche you actually see your revenues
rise across all different monetization
strategies because ultimately we do
business with people we know how do you
get known people we like how do you
actually build that affinity and people
we trust how is it that we build trust
online
again just some extra value so if you
have any questions about all that think
pat flynn.com is where the details are
you can click the link to see all those
details pat i just want to thank you so
much for adding
value to our community
final question from the author of will
it fly
uh one of my favorite books that you
wrote about launching ideas of course
your book super fans that's another side
note is like getting all of pat's books
is just kind of a no-brainer he's
absolutely world-class in his
information but
entrepreneurship the journey in
entrepreneurship has a lot of highs and
a lot of lows give us just a final
send-off for maybe some people on the
mountaintop or maybe they're in the
valley what are just some final words
from pat flynn
you know
connect with a community
of like-minded people
the most important thing i did for my
business journey
was investing in not just
content that helped me get to where i
wanted to go not just courses that
helped me with transformations but with
access to people and i know that many of
you are inside of inner circle already
and some other places but this is like
the biggest transformations in my life
have come as a result of other people
seeing things that i didn't by seeing
other people's journey before i went
down the same path
that is of massive value so if you
aren't yet a part of sean's community
or other communities online like
do that and even if you're an introvert
like me
hopefully you can realize the value in
that and the the the biggest thing is
within those communities ask for help if
you need it you know i often shied away
from that because i felt embarrassed or
i felt like i wasn't worthy or i didn't
have anything of value to give back but
you do all of you have massive value to
give because you have
care you have you you just
you step up and care about others and
things will happen right and when you
serve first the world will pay you back
in so many amazing ways so thank you so
much and randall i appreciate that
comment and i'm really looking forward
to connecting with you some of you in
the courses some of you got in already
and i'm excited to work with you in
there uh and some of you online and on
the youtubes and you know hopefully at
another growth uh or another event in
the future um with sean and
just so many opportunities to connect
and it's all about people so sean thank
you
thank you so much sir first appreciate
you and thanks again for adding massive
value uh today of course uh follow pat
you can check them out pat flynn on
instagram and uh check out links
wherever you're watching this in
description i appreciate your kind words
today smash like if you got value um and
then chris yes you absolutely can watch
this as a replay take notes and benefit
from that click or tap the screen to
watch another video if you happen to be
watching this on the youtube stream
because from here we're going to go
inside of our inner circle program to do
some q a and hot seats my name is sean
cannell ryden's with youtube channel and
i will see you in a future video or
podcast
thanks so much for being